الطائره التي وصلت
صباح هذا اليوم تحمل على متنها لوازم تشمل
خيام وبطانيات واحتياجات الاسر الضروريه
وكذلك مواد وسلال غذائيه وادويه واجهزه
طبيه ومستلزمات طبيه هذه هي الطائره
الاولى
ولدينا عدد من الطائرات سوف
يغادر خلال الساعات القادمه
بجدوله منظمه من الرياض الى حلب لضمان
الاصول المساعدات الى الاسر والمجتمع
الاكثر تضررا في سوريا دكتور ما اليات
توزيع هذه المساعدات
طبعا الاليه كما اعلناها المركز يعمل مع
مؤسسات ومنظمات المجتمع المدني الموثوقه
في الداخل السوري
منذ اكثر من يومين ادخلنا عدد كبير من
الشاحنات من الحدود التركيه السوريه الى
شمال سوريا واليوم بدا الجسر الجوي والى
الى الى حلب
وننسق في الداخل مع
مؤسساتهم منظمات مجتمع مدني سبق التعامل
معها منذ سنوات وهي موثوقه على المستوى
الدولي وعلى المستوى المحلي جيد اذا
المؤسسات ومنظمات مجتمع المجتمع المدني
يتم التنسيق معها ولكن كيف يتم التنسيق مع
الجانب السوري دكتور كيف تقيم التنسيق مع
الجانب السوري
طبعا احنا بالنسبه لهذه الطائره نسقنا مع
الهلال الاحمر السوري الذي سبق وان
تعاملنا معه
واكد لنا انه سوف يستمر كما مع عمل معنا
بالسابق باصالها الى مستحقيها والى
المنظمات التي نعمل معها كان هنالك تواصل
من خلال هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي مع
الهلال الاحمر السوري بضمان وصول هذه
المساعدات ونزول الطائرات الى الاراضي
السوريه وكما شاهدتم نزلت الطائره الاولى
ونحن الان وانا اتحدث معكم نجهز الطائره
الثانيه وسوف يتبعها اكثر من طائره لضمان
وصول هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل ومنظم الى
المحتاجين ودوي الاولويه في الداخل السوري
طبعا المعونات الانسانيه دكتور يعني هل
المساعدات السعوديه ستقتصر على ذلك ام
هناك خطه ربما للدعم في البنيه التحتيه
والتي تضررت بشكل مهول في هذا الزلزال
لا اشكرك على هذا السؤال المساعدات
السعوديه بالعكس كامله وشامله نحن الان
نستجيب
الاحتياجات الضروريه والعاجله جدا لانقاذ
الحياه كما شاهدتم فرق انقاذ اطباء كوادر
صحيه فرق متطوعين مواد اغاثيه مواد طبيه
اجهزه كذلك بطانيات خيام وكذلك اجهزه
تدفئه يتبع وكذلك الوجود على الارض يوجد
فرق تقييم للاحتياج ما بعد الاحتياجات
الطارئه من ضمنها كذلك انشاء اولا ماوى
مؤقت يتبعه كذلك ان شاء الله من خلال
الدراسات التي تقوم بها الفراغ المعنيه في
مركز الملك سلمان
بدراسه امكانيه كذلك
اعاده الاعمار
وتخفيف هذه المعاناه وهذه الكارثه
الانسانيه الكبيره